-2 Chainz, what did
you do on your birthday?
-I bought a lawn mower
and a strip club.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music rift plays ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, I bought --
I bought a -- I bought --
-You bought a lawn mower.
-And a strip club.
-And a strip club. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
So we had similar birthdays.
The three of us there.
[ Laughter ]
Wow. Wait, so what made
you want to buy?
Let's start with the --
-Both: The lawnmower.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-All right, so, um,
I have a rather large yard.
And I pay people.
I've always paid.
So I've lived in apartments
my whole life.
Then I became a rapper
and stayed in a --
I got me a house.
And then I had money.
So I paid people
to do everything for me,
like most rich people do.
And then I woke up
and I said, you know what?
I've never cut the grass before.
And I felt like...
I felt like maybe I hadn't
crossed over the threshold of --
of manhood.
And so I woke up
and I got me a John Deere.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
A zero turn.
-You got a John Deere
and a strip club
in the same week.
-Yeah.
-That is unbelievable.
That is a great story.
And the strip club open?
-Yeah, it's called Candyland.
It's in Atlanta.
Make sure you check us out.
Um, yeah. It's --
Needless to say,
it's for adults, you know?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. No.
That's true.